you are not unfunctional so if you work
a desk job nine-to-five or if you have a
training program that's very much
focused on just mirror muscles maybe you
can touch your toes maybe you can't get
a deep squat then you might have been
led to believe that your unfunctional
the truth is though you're actually
highly functional there's no such thing
that someone who's unfunctional humans
are adaptoid and you've simply adapted
to the lifestyle that you lead the range
of motion and the neural connections
that you don't use they've atrophied
over time making you a highly efficient
typing machine but the binary is not
about - making functional people is
about making super functional people so
a super functional person is someone
who's capable of doing things that
they're probably never going to need to
be able to do you get the idea it's
being ready for anything like Batman but
the problem comes when you go from that
sedentary lifestyle or perhaps a
training regime that only focuses on
mirror muscles and isolation movements -
something designed to make you more
functional when you do that that's when
you either don't see the progress that
you're hoping for or you run into
injuries that's what this video is for
if you have no experience in the gym and
this is where you start out on your
journey to being built like Batman at
the same time though I hope it will also
have use for people who perhaps have run
into a rut in their own training got
into bad habits and maybe aren't seeing
the progress that they want to or
perhaps they're experiencing limited
range of motion and aches and pains
[Music]
so my recommendation for absolute
beginners or for someone trying to go
back to basics is to start with very
light weight high repetition exercises
using isolation movements predominantly
so that means single joint or just a
couple of joints are involved an example
would be bicep curls for about 15 to 20
reps tricep pushdowns and lats pull
downs press ups maybe these exercises
are simple so you can't injure yourself
by using poor movement patterns very
easily anyways and by using those high
rep ranges were doing a few different
interesting things first of all we're
plugging the muscles with blood and
metabolites causing metabolic stress and
there's a lead to growth and that's
important because if you want to stick
to a training program you want to see
progress early on this will help with
your adherence at the same time all that
blood flow all of that pump work is
going to help to fuel the tendons and
encourage them to grow stronger and
recover thicker and more powerful this
is important because muscle grows
stronger quicker than does tendon so you
could expect to see structural changes
in your muscle after just eight days of
training but you won't see the same
thing happening your tendons until two
months so a common issue that leads to
injury is if someone gets really
strongly quick and then they pile a lot
of weight on and then they can lift it
but their tendons give out so by doing
this pump work by doing high repetition
low weight for about two months before
you get into anything more complicated
you can build yourself that foundation
get strong enough get stronger tendons
so you don't cause yourself an injury
later on as you get more advanced next
we're gonna look at mobility so I
mentioned in the introduction that one
of the big problems a lot of people have
with their training when they're
starting out is that they lack the
mobility to perform the movements they
need to perform there's a difference
between mobility and flexibility so
flexibility is the ability to get into
any position in any way you like so you
can use an external force when you're
pushing against the wall using advanced
mobility on the other hand is your
ability to get into that position
without any external assistant
flexibility and mobility are both
important and of course they'll help
each other with so many people spending
a long amounts of time sitting it's
really common for mobility to be really
poor when you're typing at a computer
you're shortening your hip flexors
you're lengthening and weakening your
glutes
you've got rounded shoulders coming
forwards
what happens is the muscles that are
being shortened in this position you're
holding for hours and hours on end get
tighter and that becomes their resting
position and consider that a lot of
people can't even get into a deep squat
without going up on their tiptoes so how
can you train like a Batman how can you
squat with a heavy weight when you can't
even get into a deep squat so we need to
fix that fortunately there are a lot of
things we can do in order to improve our
mobility and our flexibility as we start
our training journey so like I say
there's crossover between flexibility
mobility so that's one of the places to
start improve your flexibility you can
check out the video that Grant made for
the channel but basically this is going
to involve holding static stretches for
about 30 seconds that tends to be the
recommended amount of time following a
workout these don't go at the start of
the workout they go after you've lifted
the weights your body will fight you as
it gets into those positions as it's
trying to prevent you from injuring
yourself so you want to convince your
body that it's fine you need to relax
try and relax the muscles and get into a
state of calm get comfortable in that
stretched position so don't go too far
just go far enough and you feel the
stretch and then relax there hang out
there this is recommended by Pavel Tatsu
'ln author of relaxin to stret but you
should also be focusing on mobility
itself and this can go into your
workouts and the way I recommend doing
that in particular is by using very
light weights and then performing
movements like the squat like the
deadlift and watching yourself as you go
through those movements to try and see
where there are problems Kelly Starrett
author of become a SUP a leopard talks
about using training as a form of
Diagnostics tool using it to see where
your mobility issues lie you can record
yourself and watch your back for
instance or just feel where there's not
quite that range of motion or where
there's a bit of pain or resistance and
then this way you can focus on improving
that mobility before you pile the big
heavy weights on doing this as well as
the flexibility work is important
because there are other factors involved
in mobility other than just your
flexibility such as your muscle control
your ability to relax muscle and
strength your muscles need to be strong
enough to push or pull you into that
position
eccentric isometrics can also be really
useful this means getting into that
position and then adding some kind of
weight similar our weighted stretches
which I did a whole video on and I
recommend you to check out you can hold
a kettlebell whilst in a low goblet
squat position etc I'm gonna be coming
back to mobility very soon want to do
the Nightwind training part 4
closely linked to your mobility is your
core stability a lack of core strength
can also result in corrective movement
patterns such as hyperextension during
the squat and this is going to make it
more difficult you don't have that solid
scaffolding to then move freely as you
are designed to be able to do practicing
exercises like the hollow body which I
described in the previous Nightwing
video can make a big difference so of
course I'm going to incorporate lots of
that kind of thing as well as plank
which is far more useful than most
people realize as long as dually bracing
and holding that strong core position we
should also make sure at this point to
try and incorporate movements that were
going to be using during our advanced to
calisthenics training this is stuff that
you might not normally be training such
as those elbow tendons weak elbow
tendons can lead to injury if you're
trying to do movements like rope
climbing or like planche all the cool
stuff that we want to be able to
incorporate into a real superhero
metahuman training program so you can
incorporate some straight arm positions
such as the crow pose as well as support
holds on the Rings other good moves that
rings turned-out push-ups also on the
gymnastic rings or you can use see you
though planche push-ups whilst on the
calisthenics segment I also recommend
toughening up your fingers which you can
do through a whole range of things I
made a video on that also using a
fingerboard and your grip strength and
in a bit of explosive plyometric work in
there for good measure the last thing
you want to focus on as you build your
foundations for this training is your
work capacity work capacity is your
ability to perform exercise for a long
period of time without burning out the
more you can train without getting tired
to the greater work of volume you can
accomplish and the faster you'll see
that progress and if you look at
Batman's training program the one that
was shared in the Batman files you'll
see that it involves an insane amount of
pure work as you would have to include
if you were trying to train in such a
cross-modal manner there lots of things
you can do to increase work capacity and
again I made a whole video on this in
the past but one of my favorite methods
comes from the world's fittest book by
Ross Edgley and this is called a
workhorse training and this is to
include a cardio finisher at the end of
each workout but to make it a form of
resistance cardio that means that you're
not only exerting yourself in an aerobic
fashion but you're so pushing or pulling
against some form of resistance so
examples might be running up a steep
hill cycling on a tough resistance
setting rowing
seen better yet battle ropes kettlebell
swings heavy bag work anything like that
I guess your heart pumping but still
also targets the muscles and gets them
working too and all of this should help
to get the best start possible and to
train in a manner that goes beyond being
merely functional I personally put all
of this use before day routine that
being push-pull legs you'll be able to
find an example linked in the
description down below over at the bar
near comm search around this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave like please share it around
please subscribe to the channel or if
that helps me out immensely like I say
we're getting close to a hundred
thousand subscribers and when that
happens I've got some really interesting
announcements to make so stay tuned for
that thanks so much for all of your
support and I'll see you in the next one
bye for now